hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to affected one of my
favorite if not my favorite oculus rift
horror game that shows just what it can
do when a lot of work is put into it and
admittedly a lot of work has been put
into this one because this may be using
stock oculus stock unity objects but
they've done it so well there's so much
potential here there's so much work put
into it lovingly crafted into every
experience and even though it's more of
a sideshow of Horrors and especially
this one considering that I'm in a
carnival with I'm sure delightfully
dastardly clowns especially that happy
bastard over there looky so hmm
cheerfully wonderful and I'm sorry I'm
checking everything because I like I I
I'm not used to doing this setup and I
got one it's usually mr. trash cans
it's not your time to be scary yet I am
a professional and I'm doing my intro as
I walk through this area nice fire
effects I'm not even being sarcastic
those are just delight those are
delightful here anyway I got my sound
cranked up I literally don't have any
pants on and I'm ready to roll so let's
do this
dark holy wow you know it still throws
me that when I play the odds are if that
I can like look up and see these
gigantic towering things over here that
are just like loom what is that anyway
is that like a is that like a um a damn
cords coming at me everywhere so oh god
is that like a windmill or something
like that I don't know it still throws
me everyone's gonna ignore that because
just okay shut up shut up Oh what is
that a trailer okay there's something
over there that I need to know about I'm
guessing it's leading me to go into this
trailer well I'm gonna do this and I'm
gonna like it like it I wish I had the
new version of the oculus where you can
like lean forward
but that'll be in the retail version
what is it those look like bed sheets
but it looks like a good ghost sleeping
in the bed okay is they moving they're
moving
okay all right oh hi oh hi I still can't
tell if it's moving or not
are you moving can I get over to you can
I say hi to you lady oh you give me the
creeps
I Susie cannot tell if it's slightly
moving or if that's just me I'm gonna go
ahead and say it's moving and I'm gonna
get out of here okay okay okay good good
good good good
is that light shining like that before
god damn these cords these goddamn
quarter everywhere sorry everybody I'm
having technical difficulties of them
trying to get through this place oh wait
there was a wall here before I guess I
can go through here now good for me I
can't wait Hey look is that like a
powerful thing I played towerfall
recently I did good and by good I mean
bad but not bad enough to warrant like
the hatred of everyone in the entire
gaming community probably that badly
you'll see what I mean when you watch me
play but I make a comeback eventually
kinda not really you'll see I spent like
it was a big event down at Polaris where
a bunch of youtubers played in a rumble
type zone deal
we played powerful high high okay okay
all right okay okay you're not done did
you are you done now are you done now
are you really done this time can I move
forward okay Oh what is that is that a
grabby machine okay don't need to do
that I don't know what I'm supposed to
be do well let's stop doing with the
clunky noises I don't know what I'm
supposed to be doing
Oh Oh the thing Oh daddy is it a big dog
what is it dating oh I don't know I
don't know but I'm okay I'm okay so long
as I have my bravery and my fans out
there my lovely fans let's see oh I
can't go this way I gotta go towards it
good Oh what are you Oh what are you
what are you you look like a dog of some
sight a big big big big dog are you
gonna do anything
hello hi oh you're a horsey
oh you're a horsey you're you know you
okay you look a little skinny you're all
skin and bones well no skin really but
you should eat up that looks tasty
you want some water to go is it hey
you're not that scary you're just
misunderstood and missing an ear okay
all right let's move on before that
thing decide to eat me next
okay good still going still go good good
good well this has been a fun experience
but I can't wait to go home can I go up
these stairs here oh I oh I can't oh I
thought I could okay this has been fun
but I'd like to go home now eat a hotdog
excuse me could I have a hot dog okay
probably not can I test my strength okay
probably done I am going into a house of
horrors oh my goodness that is gonna be
just fun on a bun bun on a bun
okay let's do this oh my brain oh please
stop my brain okay ow ow my brain my
brain is not working in this oculus rift
oh oh that was very short-lived I
thought it was gonna be much longer than
that
oh is this what is this where am I going
Oh No walking into a maze a maze oh okay
Oh legitimate need a breather okay let's
just keep moving forward going in the
maze making my way around town walking
fast moving passing them homebound where
am I going now that I'm home bound I
don't even know but hopefully I don't
get lost for an eternity in it
girl yeah girl yeah yeah yeah right now
like it now I can't wait to keep going
on forever and ever and ever in this
carnival of Horrors oh no no no no it
couldn't meet fast enough why me I'm so
sad
no oh okay so now I'm actually going
into the ring the end oh it's at the end
Oh what do we got here oh I can see the
whole park
cool oh we're moving good good good good
oh my brain what am i doing what's going
on oh I see dead totally dead dead dead
dead at the end is at the end of my
experience in the carnival of hell oh
here yeah I think that was the end we
have a credit roll or something like
that oh whoa visit fallen planet studios
for more information about our upcoming
full feature oculist oh god oh okay all
right then
cool mark-paul that was the only name
that I really saw that's awesome oh
that's in goddamn that was amazing that
was awesome that was so much fun
I think that's calming uh-oh spelling
error everyone forget everything I said
about this game
there was a spelling error oh what a
bunch of losers over there now but
seriously that was really really well
and truly fun now let's see if there's
anything else here anything or is it
just returning me home no oh that's it
okay all right that is it
wow that was fun you know that was
actually legitimately totally and
honestly fun and that's something that's
missing from a lot of horror titles like
it's just like it scares you yeah and
maybe it was a little haunted house like
but remember going to haunted houses
during like Halloween time it's kind of
fun it's fun to do and that was fun and
well-made and well-rounded and it has
some good scares in it so there you have
it that's affected the carnival of
Horrors is here and gone but thank you
all so much for watching I can't wait to
do more oculus rift in the future I feel
a little sick though it was a little
disorienting on some of those points but
either way thank you all so much for
watching be sure to check out my oculus
rift or playlist it's in the description
there'll be an annotation there's so
many more cool oculus rift videos
thank you again everybody for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video